ladies and gentlemen ainsi monsieur
grehan votre radio podcast alors non là
c'est pas aujourd'hui le mode radio
podcast
on s'en reparle dans quelques jours
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous avez vu
j'ai déjà sorti ma toute première j'ai
failli à ma toute première vidéo de
podcasts c'est pas une vidéo de podcasts
mon tout premier podcast est déjà
disponible je vous mets le lien dans la
description
c'était sommes-nous accro à nos
smartphones aujourd'hui on va pas du
tout parlé de ça aujourd'hui on va
parler de 10 erreurs qui met en danger
votre smartphone
10 erreurs que vous faites probablement
d'ailleurs je compte sur vous pour me le
dire en bon commentaire au fur et à
mesure quand vous voyez une erreur que
vous faites vous mettez la pause vous me
le marquer mon commentaire comme ça
gérer un petit peu ce sont des tout ça
et voir si vous commettez des erreurs
avec votre smartphone
alors je vous déculpabiliser tout de
suite j'enlève le problème j'enlève les
questionnements j'ai fait des erreurs
j'ai fait des erreurs j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses et je voulais
transmettre c'est pour ça que je viens
vous faire cette vidéo bas pour dire est
a fait des avancées très bien on fait
tous des erreurs je continue à en faire
mais autant sa portée des choses dans
les autres et moi j'essaie de vous
apporter quelques connaissances que j'ai
acquises comme ça ça peut vous permettre
d'éviter de faire ces mêmes erreurs donc
pour revenir au podcast le lien et la
clique est allé voir
j'ai aussi créé une chaîne dédiée
fréquence greva vous cliquez vous aurez
toutes les listes août la liste tous les
endroits où pour retrouver le podcast
apple musique deezer spotify youtube
bien évidemment google podcast il est
partout c'est très cool c'est vrai
qu'entre aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil
aujourd'hui on parle en cas d'erreur qui
met en danger vos smartphones et puis
bien évidemment une fois n'est pas
coutume je vous invite à venir vous
abonner si vous ne savez pas tout si
vous n'êtes pas déjà abonnés à la chaîne
si vous n'êtes pas abonné c'est pas bien
venez vous abonner comme ça vous aurez
tout de l'acte i tech les nouveautés les
smartphones les montrent les tablettes
et toutes les bonnes conduites à avoir
que ce soit pour éviter des erreurs pour
ne pas mettre en danger vos smartphones
des erreurs concernant l'autonomie de
votre smartphone améliorer la durée de
vie de votre batterie
il ya plein de choses c'est pour vous
vous cliquez sur un petit bouton qui
situent juste là vous actionnez la
cloche et on y est c'est cool nous voilà
donc parti pour dix erreurs que vous
faites et qui met en danger vos
smartphones
la toute première erreur et on le fait
tous un c'est de mettre des codes trop
facile alors bien souvent on a des code
à quatre chiffres des fois il ya des
codes à six chiffres
ça fait beaucoup de doigts et bien je
vous déconseille de mettre des codes
trop facile alors qu'est ce qu'un code
trop facile le code de base 0 0 0 0 et
si je vous dis ça c'est parce que je
connais des personnes qui le font encore
actuellement qui met les 4 0
éviter parce que si quelqu'un vient
récupérer votre smartphone si vous vous
le faites voler autant que vous donnez
soit protégé donc si vous mettez l'e40
claque ça craint évitez également le 1 2
3 4 et les choses qui sont beaucoup trop
facile comme ça évite également votre
année de naissance pour un peu que
quelqu'un puisse savoir auquel année
vous êtes né d'avoir aucun mal à dire
déverrouiller ou avoir accès en tout cas
à toutes les informations de votre
smartphone pense à des codes un peu
complexe des choses qui ne coulerait pas
de source
ça peut vraiment tenir vous solutionner
la ville d'ailleurs je profite à la fin
de la vidéo je vous donne plusieurs
bonus
au delà des 10 points qu'on regarde
aujourd'hui comme ça ça vous permettra
d'avoir quelques bonnes astuces en plus
ne nous remerciez pas c'est pas grave ça
fait plaisir c'est pour moi c'est cadeau
le deuxième point c'est un peu dans la
continuité du code trop facile c'est les
schémas si vous êtes sur android les
schémas sont légion et autant
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
smartphones qui se débrouillent avec des
lecteurs d'empreintes digitales
autant le schéma est bien dans beaucoup
de smartphones on continue à bien
l'utiliser si vous me faites des schémas
avec un espèce de c'est un truc trop
simple sagesse de venir mettre en danger
vos informations personnelles ne fait
pas pour c'est vraiment à sécuriser
votre smartphone et faites-moi des
schémas un petit peu tordu un petit peu
complexe ça pourra bien vous éviter
quelques déconvenues
le troisième point je suis sûr qu on le
fait tous quasiment tous en bouche on va
dans un hôtel pour les vacances ou pour
le travail ou pour ce que vous voulez
mais ça ne me regarde pas vous allez
dans un restaurant vous avez des wifi
public et vous n'avez pas de vpn vous
n'avez rien qui vient vous sécurisez
alors si vous ne savez pas ce qu'est
hervé penot j'en ai déjà parlé plusieurs
fois ça va créer un tunnel sécurisé au
niveau de votre connexion entre vous et
le site distant ça vient tout cryptée et
lorsque vous êtes dans un wifi public si
vous n'avez pas de vpn quelqu'un qui s'y
connaît alors c'est pas tout un chacun
mais quelqu'un qui s'y connaît peut
venir intercepter tout donner et vous
êtes exposés comme une dinde en période
de noël je vous laisse imaginer truc la
quatrième fois que vous faites pas
forcément c'est ne pas activer la
localisation de votre smartphone ça vous
permettra lorsque vous le perdez ou si
vous le faites vous voulez et bien dans
un temps assez court de pouvoir savoir
où est votre smartphone et
éventuellement pouvoir signaler aux
forces de l'ordre
ou alors d'aller chercher si vous le
perdez bien évidemment si vous faites
voler ap la police
c'est un poids qui peut paraître tout
bête mais que tout le monde ne fait pas
et croyez moi pourtant ça peut venir
vous permettre de récupérer vos
smartphones dans de très nombreux cas le
cinquième point et je suis sûr je suis
quasiment sûr que vous êtes très
nombreux et très nombreux à faire vous
utilisez le
et mot de passe pour toutes vos
applications pour peu que vous utilisez
le même mot de passe pour déverrouiller
votre smartphone les rend extrêmement
mal c'est très important
on n'est pas que dans la sécurité du
smartphone un peu au delà de tout ça
pensez vraiment avoir des mots de passe
différents et si vous avez peur de ne
pas vous en souvenir ce que je vous
conseille de faire à ce moment là et
bien c'est d'utiliser des services
dédiés qui vont venir centraliser tous
vos mots de passe
vous n'avez qu'à activer le service avec
un seul et même mot de passe ça va venir
vous identifier très facilement et de
façon extrêmement sécurisé il y en a
plein qui existe j'ai déjà parlé de la
spa s'il ya très longtemps
les google qui fait serre d ici à apple
qui le fait il y en a beaucoup et je
vous le conseille plus plus plus c'est
extrêmement important
un autre point qui est extrêmement
essentiel qui est très important vous ne
faites pas forcément les mises à jour de
vos smartphones
il faut le faire il faut le faire même
si des fois on dit j'ai peur qu'il se
met à ramer que ça aille moins bien
faites-le c'est extrêmement important
fait les mises à jour parce que dans les
mises à jour est effectivement des
petites nouveautés et ça on peut se dire
qu'on peut venir sans passé mais bien
souvent ce sont des correctifs de bugs
qui viennent vous protéger et éviter des
intrusions dans votre smartphone et
éviter de mettre en danger votre
smartphone donc dès que vous voyez
quelle mise à jour qui apparaît fait la
mise à jour bien des constructeurs qui
font ça vraiment bien chez apple ils
font des mises à jour très régulièrement
chez one place également fait les mises
à jour ça peut également venir vous
éviter quelques problèmes un autre point
et sachant qu'on est aussi très nombreux
à le faire lorsque vous installez une
nouvelle application que vous activez un
nouveau service bien souvent vous
demande d autorisation et nous les
précèdent les utiliser ceci étant dit
entre nous ça nous embête de lire tout
ce qu'on nous écrit sauf que c'est
extrêmement important
ça veut dire que vous donner des
autorisations à des applications que
vous ne connaissez pas forcément à
pouvoir accéder à vos contacts
accédez à vos photos accédez à pas mal
de choses que vous ne voudriez pas
forcément voir étaler donc avant
d'accepter regarder vraiment ce qu'il
aurait d'ailleurs il ya un point le cas
été développés c'est le fait d'accéder à
la localisation de votre smartphone par
les applications tierces android
notamment vous le propose en dix ans joe
torre cette application a accédé à ma
localisation en permanence uniquement
lorsque la peau est active ou alors ne
pas autoriser par défaut cochet lorsque
la est active uniquement quand la paix
fermer l'application ne peut pas savoir
où vous situez et en termes de vie
privée c'est quand même vraiment
beaucoup mieux ça veut pas dire que les
applications que vous installez vont
venir vous pirater mais cette question
de donner de vie privée est extrêmement
importante parce que d'une secte immense
et pas toujours
qui a derrière cette application et même
quand vous êtes sur vos données
personnelles sont privés sont pour vous
et il n'y a aucune raison que x
applications et accès à votre
localisation permanence et accès à vos
contacts accès à vos photos de sa non
voilà donc soyez extrêmement vigilant
regarder vraiment ce que vous venez
autorisé si vous avez autorisé déjà des
choses un petit peu douteuse
allez voir dans les paramètres de votre
smartphone vous pouvez rectifier tout ça
huitième point huitième point et là je
vous parle plus de danger physique vous
ne mettez pas de coques de protection
sur vos smartphones alors je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord un smartphone
quand on l'achète
on l'achète aussi pour le look on veut
qu'il soit beau on est fier de pouvoir
le montrer à ses amis et puis surtout on
a du plaisir à le regarder et des fois
on va se dire ok je vais mettre une
coque mais ça va venir cacher mon
smartphone alors il existe des codes
très belle qui vont mettre en valeur
votre smartphone moi j'ai sinon j'ai
cela sur mon iphone voyez c'est une coop
transport en fourni par apple ça marche
bien pensé vraiment à mettre des coques
de protection puisque lorsque votre
smartphone sera tombée vous serez très
content de ne pas avoir un dock assez de
ne pas avoir un smartphone éclaté qui
part en lambeaux
j'en ai beaucoup parlé je vous en
reparlerai encore ça c'est un point qui
est vraiment très important et tout le
monde ne le fait pas encore neuvième
point c'est le truc du parano un peu
lorsque vous êtes en terrasse avec des
amis que vous mangez quelque chose ou
buvez un coup vous laissez votre
smartphone posé sur la table à côté de
vous alors il ya des endroits où
effectivement ça craint absolument rien
mais moi lorsque je suis à paris je ne
le fais pas je ne le fais jamais j'ai
tellement vu de vol se faire comme ça
j'ai tellement d'amis qui sont fait
voler des smartphones alors à l'arraché
là effectivement bon pas faire grand
chose mais le poser sur une table
c'est toujours prendre un risque
supplémentaire il ya des endroits où je
pourrai le faire à clermont ferrand je
me sentirai quand même un peu plus à
l'aise mais à paris jamais et vous savez
souvent il ya des personnes qui viennent
avec des petites pétition de définir car
des cinémas pétition il vous la mettre
sous le nez vous vous voyez rien et le
temps hop ils prennent la pétition ils
prennent le smartphone ils s'en vont ni
vu ni connu le temps vous vous rendiez
compte la personne est déjà loin et
voient smartphones il est parti donc là
vous met une phase plus en danger vos
données si elles peuvent être récupérés
avec un mot de passe trop facile
notamment les 4 0 et en plus de ça vous
a plu smartphone est le dixième point
j'ai vraiment voulu venir ajouté parce
que je suis sûr vous êtes extrêmement
nombreux extrêmement nombreux d'ailleurs
dites le moi en bas en commentaire à ne
pas faire de sauvegarde de votre
smartphone
quand on l'a dans la main quand tout
marche bien on se pose pas la question
de dieu et c'est bon je lis avec moi il
ya aucun problème mais c'est le jour où
on
perdus où on a cassé ou il a cramé et
qu'on a perdu tous ses souvenirs sur
plusieurs années qu'on a les boules
il existe beaucoup de solutions vous
avez du créole un peu partout tout le
monde propose ça si votre fabricant ne
le propose pas bien on peut toujours le
faire avec google et si vous n'aimez pas
google peut le faire avec dropbox
sauvegarder vos données dans le cloud et
silk lot c'est pas votre truc dans un
ordinateur et faites-le très
régulièrement pour ne pas risquer de
voir disparaître vos données et au delà
de vos données vos souvenirs voilà pour
les diplomates on va faire un tour du
côté des bonus parce que oui il ya
encore plein de choses à dire un point
qui est important c'est un peu une
extension c'est d'utiliser la double
authentification
si vous utilisez par exemple les
services de google de facebook
d'instagram pour ne citer qu'eux vous
pouvez activer une double identification
on va venir vous envoyez un sms pour
valider que c'est bien vous qui
demandait à vous connecter
effectivement cette question sécurité
pas que pour smartphones également pour
ordinateur mais je préférais quand même
voulu dire et c'est parce que c'est un
point très important moi je le fais je
vais vraiment à la sécurité pensez
vraiment à venir sécuriser une fois de
plus vos réseaux sociaux parce que ce
sont justement des réseaux sociaux ce
sont les liens avec vos amis qui
contiennent plein d'informations
personnelles et vous ne voudriez pas que
n'importe qui puisse en prendre le
contrôle
autre point concernant la question
d'antivirus on se demande souvent est ce
que j'ai besoin d'un antivirus sur mon
smartphone moi la réponse est non non
dans la mesure où vous ne prenez pas de
risque dans la mesure où toutes les
applications vous voulez télécharger ce
sont des applications qui sont issus de
votre catalogue d'applications officiel
l'app store la galerie le plextor alors
il ya un peu le cas un peu exceptionnel
je vous en ai parlé pour moi ou les
applications qui ne sont pas encore
présentes dans la galerie vous voudrais
pouvoir vous téléchargez ce sont les
fameuses à pk vous pouvez récupérer des
apk officiels notamment sur le site de
facebook ou de whatsapp vous connaissez
la provenance donc il n'y a absolument
aucun risque
mais n'allez pas télécharger des
applications sur un site que vous ne
connaissez pas ou vous n'êtes pas sûr de
la source puisque vous ne savez pas
réellement ce qui va s'installer après
dans votre smartphone
et puis d'année conseil c'est le fait de
venir chiffrer vos données ça veut dire
qu'elles sont protégés ça veut dire que
tout le monde ne peut pas y avoir accès
c'est un petit peu en plus mais malgré
tout il a toute son importance à vous de
me dire maintenant vous en bas en
commentaire quelle erreur vous avez
commis quelques erreurs vous commettez
encore aujourd'hui et est ce que vous
pensez que cette vidéo et les quelques
astuces que je vous donne vont vous
permettre vraiment de solutionner ce
problème est de ne pas exposer votre
smartphone à tout vent à tous
pirates à tout voleur qui existeraient
de pouvoir son appareil mark et moi tout
ça bien évidemment en bas on commentaire
quant à nous je trouve extrêmement
rapidement dans le podcast de sortir un
numéro très très très très très bientôt
en tout cas à l'heure à laquelle ce
sondage vidéo peut-être demain peut-être
après non ça ne va pas tarder il y en a
plein qui vont arriver
ça va être extrêmement cool bien
évidemment plein de vidéos sur youtube
plein de tutos plein d'astuces plein de
tests j'ai reçu plein de nouveautés ça
va être très cool sens aux jambes a
beaucoup d'amour beaucoup d'amour dans
le micro prenez soin de moi je vous fais
un petit bisou comme ça en mode pro
model et sa mère salut bisous les soins
de fou coca cola icmr j'ai du mal avec
la slr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]